[MUSIC PLAYING]
ASHLEY THOMAS: I'm Ashley
Thomas, a cognitive scientist
at the McGovern
Institute, at MIT.
I use puppets to
study baby minds
and how babies make sense
of the world around them.
People used to think that
babies didn't understand
much at all about the world,
but now, we know that's wrong.
Babies understand a lot.
Even though babies can't
talk, their behavior
provides clues about
what they're thinking.
Babies look at people
and things they like,
and they focus their
attention where
they expect things to happen.
So to figure out what
a baby is thinking,
I measure what they look at.
Here's what I mean.
This is baby Ursula.
She is watching Sarah
share food with a puppet.
Now, Ursula sees a
different person, Laura,
passing a ball with the puppet.
What happens if the
puppet starts crying?
Who will comfort the sad
puppet, Sarah or Laura?
Ursula can't tell us what she is
thinking, but she can show us.
When Ursula looks
at Sarah first,
it tells me that she expects
Sarah to comfort the puppet.
These types of
experiments show us
that babies do understand a lot
about the world around them,
including complex
social relationships.